[Applause]
Brendan Fraser will be out here in just
a little bit but some of you may know
last weekend in in San Diego was the
39th annual comic-con comic book
convention
now comic-con has become a huge event
showcasing the latest in movies
television and animation this year it's
just as how big it's gotten over 120,000
people attended was it turns out our
good friend triumph the insult comic dog
was there to plug a DVD that he was
featured on he's a [ __ ] so we figured
out why not send a camera crew with
triumph so he could share all the
excitement of comic-con with us here is
his report the majesty that these comic
cons here normalcy is the outsider and
the deviant and aberrant reign supreme
as giant media companies shamelessly
throw themselves at nerds his feet it is
truly a golden era for these unbathed
overweight and friendless trendsetters
in Concord Hollywood perhaps someday
they will conquer basic hygiene so
what's your thing you guys are supposed
to be Spartans Spartans okay so you and
I fight to the death with your sexuality
what movie is this oh you're a bathroom
star Galactica guys here we go
set your phasers on loser I love these
people these are my people they really
are you know they're into the comic
books I I for years I used to love
reading comic books then I turned seven
San Diego yes a terrific website for me
to never go on
hey guys from GI Joe may the loneliness
be with you one more thing can I give
you a wedgie one of the panel's Pokemon
oh yeah there was a huge line for people
to play Pokemon he's an even bigger line
of people waiting to beat the out of you
[Music]
in the future people swing free
everybody guns are made of wood
[Laughter]
I'm talking to the king of internet
predators to eight-year-old boys hidden
in there okay you're not dressed as
anything do you like superheroes though
yeah you're obviously looks to me like
you're a fan of the fantastic four food
groups this is an incredible character
he actually cut himself on a hoagie okay
how are you doing good what merchandise
are you selling obviously not waste loss
I can't believe I haven't run out of fat
jokes yet this is this is basically you
in purple imagination what did the
designers you looked in the mirror and
you made it blue and now we've got the
Joker here yeah sorry folks the guy is
still getting adjusted to West Coast
time he's three hours back it's normal
masturbating schedule it's now what's
this all right well I'm a melon
you're obviously a dog wait wait widen
and get the Freak - there's nothing
funnier than seeing the lame puppeteer
this is a great thing I kid that great
it's terrific I just want to know just
to clear up one thing for me if you're
here who's home disappointing your
parents I've got the quiz for you guys
okay I want you to identify this all
right what is this what's that who's
this Boba Fett okay okay good let's see
if any of you can get this what they
[Applause]
know women disqualified what what are
you supposed to be Oh No
okay this is what's known as lowering
the bar what do you do what's your
superpower
I think your super powers to kill
erections
you're a nice Joker can I give you a
wedgie okay see what the Joker keeps it
you Joker's watching his wave that's
nice
[Music]
[Applause]
are you you're not trying to get a guy
here are you really that's the matter
the homeless shelter was all fooled up
folks over by the NBC booth you'll see
the cast of junk pretending to like you
Hanover and pretend to like them let's
all take part is the big life together
yes
watch it Bob I see right in character
you really cocky aren't you look at me
I've wasted four months growing
sideburns for today excuse me my pagers
running that's a message from reality it
says you're in a public place
dressed as Wolverine here's a little
preachy when he gets home use the
Incredible Hulk at all this is the
Incredible Hulk Swank face it's safer
than that masturbate away
when I look out on this crowd I see
enough virgins to make a suicide bomber
[Applause]
many of you have not even seen that part
to Vijaya but the light is your night so
make the most of it
make the most of this weekend don't hold
that go up to Stanley and ask him to
sign your boner
yes you have one you have one but you
can't be better
and in that spirit I invite all of you
to stand up right now
[Music]
[Applause]
give yourselves a hand
[Applause]
[ __ ] on speech at NBC very nice crazy
beer